30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
hi guys it's joe last year so today's
workout it's slightly different from my
usual workout today's workout is a
indoor walking challenge so for the next
30 days I want to challenge you to walk
at least 10,000 steps every single day
okay
walking is probably one of the most
underrated workout walking is a great
cardio workout and it is low-impact
therefore it's suitable for anybody and
everybody so for those who of you who
might be overweight and you want to
start to get active or maybe you might
have old knee injuries then this workout
is for you
so let's start marching and I will be
going through the different variations
okay
so just start marching on the spot you
do not need a big space at all you can
do it from the comfort of your own home
right in your living room okay so it
will be a 30 seconds of March and 30
seconds of a step workout alright let's
keep things fun and interesting okay
good so it's just march on the spot
very good and the first workout is going
to be a slight tap okay so what a way to
do is just tap your side tap to your
side okay good there you go as far as
you can laughs - right okay and remember
to keep your knees soft keep your knees
slightly bent because you don't be
putting the strain on your knees okay
this is a really good low-impact workout
keep going
sidestep sidestep and good let's try the
head keep your body upright remember to
focus on your posture as well sidestep
and it's back to marching good and just
relax your upper body okay we take your
shoulders grow your shoulders back row
your should I spoil it keep your back
straight
type in your core and just swing your
arms left and right very good
keep marching okay so you don't always
have to go out there to hit 10,000 steps
you can do this workout from the comfort
of your own home
alright now let's go to tap good so feel
the stretch on your cuffs slightly okay
heel tap reach and reach good again
coordinating your heels with your arms
tap and tap alright do you feel your
heart rate starting to rise slightly
that's good that means your body is
starting to burn fat good and we want
this because we want to increase your
metabolism and keep going back to
marching
good if you want to challenge yourself
you can always bring your knees slightly
higher up okay
every time you much bring your knees
slightly higher up good keep marching
and the next step is going to be a
narrow to wide step all right so we want
to also work on your glutes that's why I
love walking exercises because you're
not only working on your legs but your
glutes as well as your core okay so go
narrow white narrow wide good spread it
out good step wipe step narrow all right
there you go
as you step wide go low okay try to push
yourself go lower into a squat nice
narrow and wide step in and out go lower
every time you go nice push it down and
up very good step in and out last few
more and just breathe in breathe out
catch your breath
take this time to shake it out a little
bit if you need to shake it out stretch
up slightly and just bring your heart
rate back down a little bit good keep
marching okay
do not stop marching throughout the
entire workout you can slow the pace
down but do not stop very good and now
let's work on Lakers so what are you do
is curl your left leg and your right leg
up okay so again spreading your arms
apart and working on your chest and your
back muscles as well okay so left curl
right good try to bring your heels close
to your gluts
okay so heels to your butt heels
kicking back to your body very good and
spreading your arms back good keep going
and rest March it out I'm feeling good
I'm feeling like I am having a good
workout from the comfort of my own home
very good now
what you'll need for the next step
workout it's a little bit of space
forward and also back because we were
too much to step forward and to step
back ok all right let's keep marching
relax the upper body swing your arms
work on the core and let's go forward
step and back forward step and back good
forward step stay low and back if you
want to change yourself go lower okay
forward step and back very good keep
going tap and touch just like a dunce if
you want to swing your hips a little bit
up and back keep going
swing those hips move those hips and
back good forward and back and it just
March it out okay for those of you who
have been following my workout videos
you will also know that I love
kickboxing and therefore I do have a
kickboxing cardio workout on my channel
as well so for the next step workout I
want to add a little bit of punches just
to keep things fun ok so what I want to
do is step up as you twist point and
punch ok so making sure that you're
pointing and punching ok with this
workout really work on twisting your
torso sucking your belly in and punch
alright good twist and punch I remember
as you punch do not just let your arms
drop keep both arms close to your face
twist and punch good keep going nice see
your shoulders working for your arms
working toning up on the entire body ok
good stop it out very good
ok bring your knees up and just breathe
one of the tricks to make sure that you
can complete the entire workout or to
make sure that you can improve on your
workout is to pace your breathing it
extremely important the better you pace
up
breathing the better you will sustain
your workout okay so don't just go
really pace your breathing good alright
next skater what I want to do is just
drive your left leg cross over to your
right okay just step and twist again
moving your hips step and twist good
working on a hip rotation as well step
and twist step and twist okay one two we
can reach reach and reach very good last
few more step and reach March it out
good remember I want to challenge you to
drive your knee up even higher so for
the next step workout but what I'm going
to do is really bring your knee if
possible in line with your lower chest
okay so just match it up first take this
time to catch your breath all right
and now let's drive your knee up okay so
up and tap up and tap okay up and tap
reach your hands up and tap good there
you go hands up and tap feel the crunch
I feel the work on your abs as well up
and tap good keep going we reach up view
the lengthening on your back and tap
good doing really well last one more and
March it out okay still working on some
kickboxing moves okay the next one let's
work on some front kicks okay this is
gonna be really fun
okay so keep matching out to begin with
just breathe keep marching let's not
stop right now remember you can slow
down your March slow it down if you need
to but don't stop all right okay
all right let's go give me some front
kicks let's go front kicks front kicks
you want to challenge yourself and rich
kick to the front kick good reach and
kick so stepping workouts are walking
workouts it's not all that boring let's
spice it up and let's make it fun step
whoop step it up and reach reach and
kick use the muscles and strength from
your legs if you can't go as high then
start no okay low kicks good and March
it out
alright let's get some space on your
left and also your right side okay we
want to go double step to the right and
double step to the left okay
so find some space in your home good
keep marching keep marching keep going
watch your breath if you need to at any
point
drink some water keep yourself hydrated
okay it is very important to keep
yourself hydrated let's go double step
tap double step and tap good and tap and
tap tap okay and stay low
and tap good let's reach up and reach
and reach up and reach good keep going
and reach few more left and right left
and right haha not stopping right now
okay let's check alright I already have
2000 steps on my watch right now okay
let's aim for at least 5 to 6,000 steps
for this workout alright keep marching
keep going okay
the next exercise let's work more on
your core standing twisted crunch
alright so what I want to do is place
both hands up stand and crunch stand and
crush step and crunch good again
if this is a challenge don't worry you
don't have
to compete with other people just bring
your knee as high as you can okay if you
want to challenge yourself then go all
the way up and reach for your elbow all
right it's not about dropping remember
keeping your elbow up and reach good
keep going
standing twisted crunch very good last
few more and March it out
good okay again roll your shoulders okay
roll your shoulders back roll your
shoulders forward catch your breath and
just stretch it up back down stretch it
up back down good few more stretch it up
and back down okay now let's go for a
square walk so imagine you're drawing a
square front and back okay run them back
keeping your legs wide all the way
through front and back and front and
back for more challenge go lower get
into a squat position go lower
walk front and back running back okay
now let's change side left right and
left right okay feel your glutes feel
your quads working few more and March it
out
oh very good all right now what I'm
going to do is take a step forward okay
stand forward because for the next step
workout we want to step back all right
so it's sort of like a regressed reverse
lunge okay so step forward March March
it out and now let's try it let's take a
left leg back step back right leg back
okay so this is the first alternative
all right if you want to challenge
yourself then go lower and try to reach
for the floor all right if you want to
reach and bend your knees into a lunge
good reach down tap down
tap if this is too much for you then
just take a step back that's it
step back step forward and step back
very good step back and forward huh
all right okay again March it out okay
see I'm being really nice I'm giving you
like a short break in between every
exercise and you should be sweating
right now because I know I am so keep
marching keep marching it out alright
two more exercises and we want to repeat
the entire circuit once more okay so
just keep marching all right for the
next workout
place both hands close your waist I went
to go side to side twist again pointing
and really reaching as far as you can
okay point and rich now let's go up and
reach up and reach side side side side
Alexa go down down down down side side
side side let's run up up up and up okay
March it out I save the last workout
probably the best workout just for you
as well okay so it's going to be a white
speed walk challenge yourself and walk
as fast as you can okay so March it out
catch your breath breathe in
remember again let's work on the upper
body just allow your arms to swing side
to side okay now step wide ready and
walk as fast as you can if this is too
much then just take a white step as fast
as you can okay
tiptoe if not you can even run on the
spot if you want to okay so really turn
it yourself type in your car okay
keeping your body in a straight line and
just walk as fast as you can okay
imagine you're running on the spot with
your clicks wide open keep going
run step tap tap tap tap tap must feel
more happy
and March it out wow that was a good
cardio blaster okay
let's repeat the entire workout again
all right you know all the exercises by
now
so let's challenge yourself a little bit
more and keep your heart rate up
throughout
okay so just march on the spot to begin
with boom
again if edit at any point you feel like
you need to release some tension from
your upper body feel free to do so
okay let's stop slight tap okay reach
and reach okay you can stretch your left
arm and your right arm out reach and
reach
tap and tap good there you go looking
really good let's go sides up reach and
reach nice whoa let me know in the
comments below if you're feeling this
workout if you're sweaty and if you want
more of it keep going
nice March it out
good okay challenge yourself speed up
the match okay treat this as your
workout as well don't treat it as a
brick so speed of your March much
quicker okay speed walk speed wine good
speed walk keep going and breathe okay
ha all right next let's go he'll tap
he'll tap again
let's bring the speed up good I'm up
alternate good he'll tap he'll tap let's
go bring the speed up keep going we're
not stopping right now let's go halfway
there bring the speed up nice keep going
come on go tap and tap tap and tap it's
intense but it's going back tapping tap
two more and March it out again speed
walk okay let's go Speed Walker let's
bring your heart rate up breathe in and
breathe out
okay now let's start from a narrow to a
wide step okay again second round let's
challenge yourself even more up up up
let's go narrow white narrow one keep
going narrow white good keeping your
chest up do not hunt you over okay keep
your chest up look forward keep your
foundation keep your base low good in
and out very nice in and out in and out
good I can feel my glutes on fire and
you shoot to stay low white and no good
white and no nice and March it out
breathe Wow
they say that sweat is your fat crying
okay so sweat is good we want to burn
fat we want to increase lean muscles and
we want to increase your metabolism keep
going keep marching and good okay let's
work on some lake curls again remember
the goal is to drive your heels to your
butt okay let's go Lakers spread your
arms out that's up and down okay working
on your shoulders
and your back muscles as well reach up
and down nice ah ha let's go you should
start to really feel that you have the
power to push through this entire
workout you have less than 10 minutes
okay March it out oh my gosh
who says walking can make you sweat who
say it's walking it's not a good workout
not everybody can run and I do
understand that and that's the reason
why I believe that walking is probably
one of the best exercises to really burn
fat and to keep you healthy
okay keep marching and I'll find some
space forward and back okay let's go
forward tap back just like a cha-cha-cha
dance back forward tap back tap forward
and back swing your hips nice suede let
me see your hips sway left to right nice
there you go move your waist move your
arms very good tap left and right hah
this is not my usual we're done but I
know I'm having fun all right
March it out how are you doing
stiffening good yeah
can we keep going yes I hear you
let's go let's keep marching okay all
right let's work more on your hips let's
work on skaters okay
so for the next workout what I want to
do is cross your left foot behind your
right and your right foot behind your
left let's go cross tap cross and tap ok
if you want it rich and rich there you
go nice tap and tap good
tap and tap okay skater tap and turn ice
just crossing over if you want to
challenge yourself and go lower into a
small cut see lunch okay tap and tap tap
and tap all right
let's March it out remember just roll
your shoulders back row your shoulders
forward and just breathe in and out okay
let's add in some kick boxing moves okay
twist and punch I love this give me a
strong punch okay so start with both
arms close to your face all right let's
go
twist and punch point your toes and
punch strong punch do not drop your
shutters keep your shoulders in the same
line with your aunts twist and punch
good keep stopping keep punching right
in your car working on your hips and
twist total rotation let's go last few
more punch punch and punch oh okay do
not stop keep going keep walking keep
marching
alright next really simple
high knees okay try to drive your knee
as high as you can I would say start
with your belly button to begin with
okay and now let's bring the pace down
slow it down a little bit and now let's
go up tap and up good bring it up and up
okay it's not about driving your arms
down but rather it's about bringing your
knees up good point your toes as you
drive your knees up good there you go
feel the crunch on your apps as well
crunch it
very good last few more drive it up
very good doing really well keep going
and March it out
ah stay with me okay stay with me do you
not stop the workout right now do not
stop this video right now stay with me
okay
you have only less than what about eight
exercises left - stay with me good
now show me some strong kicks okay
strong kicks and reach for your kicks
really kick kicking it like you mean it
alright let's go forward kick kick reach
and kick right kick as high as you can
rich and kick very good check it out
kick it forward rich and if you want to
you can even tap on your toes reach and
kick and kick nice keep going last few
more hah rich and kick and martial arts
look at this I'm drenched in sweat so
yeah ah right let's check our steps
three thousand and five hundred at the
moment okay
keep marching keep marching
good breathe in and breathe out alright
find some space on your left and also
your right side okay we want to go for
double side stab okay and let's just
point and reach right again so double
point and tap okay
reach and tap good there you go reach up
and tap good double step and tap now
let's challenge yourself bring your
squat no we're okay
lower yourself down
nice double step double step last few
more and March it out
ha keep walking and probably one of my
favorite workouts standing twisted
crunch so we're getting on your ass it's
not all about lying down on the floor or
you know working on the mat you can also
work on your core by standing up to
begin with okay right so standing
twisted crunch start with both arms
close to your body and twist and reach
okay try to reach your knee to the
opposite elbow again it's not about
dropping your hand okay
this is wrong stay high up twist and
reach if this is too tough then just
only go as far as you can to begin with
twist that little bit is good enough the
important point is to work on your torso
as you progress and as you keep doing
this work out then reach further all
right and March it out
very good very good okay we are almost
there keep marching
remember engage your core
throughout okay what does it mean turn
get your core I want you to feel like
you're squeezing your abs inwards and
that whatever workout you do you have
that strong core foundation because by
having a strong core you will be able to
improve any performance and avoid
unnecessary injuries okay so low square
walk let's draw a square that low and
walk it back and forward good forward
and back
nice stay low okay let's challenge
yourself stay low forward and back
forward and back okay now let's switch
over left leg first fold them back and
followed by the right foot stay low
forward and back forward and back
last few more one more good all right
now take one big step forward okay and
keep marching keep marching and the next
variation is a step back if you want to
challenge yourself go lower go deeper
into every first latch all right so just
keep marching to begin with oh I am
feeling really good let's go step back
step back okay if you want to reach
lower into a reverse lunge right reach
lower bend your knees in a 90-degree
position reach lower and reach lower
good point down reach down tap and reach
okay
nice keep going as far as you can bend
your knees into a reverse lunge
that's one more and back up okay all
right March it out Oh two more exercises
okay
two more exercises and you are done okay
so it's going to be a side to side twist
all right so March it out
catch your breath let's go for speed
walking right now speed walk do you not
slow down keep tapping keep merging and
now let's go slight twist okay let's
start here and now let's reach up twist
and quit really twist your hips twist
your torso and reach back again twist
okay good
and now let's reach down down tap and
down good middle side-to-side and now
let's reach up up up and up good huh
March it out one final exercise one
final workout and you are done can you
believe it it's almost 13 minutes keep
merging and this is going to be the
cardio blaster okay white speed walk try
to really speed up your walk go as fast
as you can get into a sprint and really
put yourself for only 30 seconds ready
let's go and sprint Oh walk as fast as
you can okay keeping your toes pointed
out and your body low all right
speed walk keep pointing stop stop do
you mark on do not stop right now you're
halfway there ten more seconds keep
going
walk it out filling it and just March it
out okay oh very very very well done so
my challenge to you for the next 30 days
and even beyond is to hit at least
10,000 steps every single day okay it
can be you doing this workout combined
with your daily outdoor activities all
right so let's check it right now I have
hit slightly above 4,000 steps so you
can choose to repeat this workout twice
a day which gives you a 1-hour solid
workout for the day or try to hit your
steps while you're out and about choose
to walk instead of using like your regal
or your public transport okay
my heart rate is high right now I'm
feeling really good I'm sweating and I
know that my metabolism is also high and
that is what I want for you so be sure
to check out my other low-impact
workouts on my youtube channel check out
lots of healthy recipes as well as
nutritional tips to guide you through
your fitness journey and if you haven't
yet subscribed to my youtube channel
if you are new then hit the subscribe
button and turn on your notifications so
that you will get notified every time I
upload a new video all the best